merci Olivier Pacaud nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi heure
rattaché au groupe les républicains
neuvième journée de mobilisation la
première depuis l'adoption du texte par
le Parlement de nombreux manifestants
dans les ruillères est-ce qu'il faut
entendre le message de la rue reculer
sur cette réforme
on ne peut pas ne pas entendre le
message de la rue et ce ne sont pas les
violences ou la chiant Lee qui ça et là
effectivement ternissent le mouvement
qui peuvent faire penser qu'il n'y a pas
un vrai malaise il y a eu un problème
sur la méthode il y a un problème de
gouvernance la balle est dans le camp
d'abord du Conseil constitutionnel mais
surtout du président de la République
alors il avait plusieurs options il
pouvait éventuellement remanier c'était
peut-être la chose la plus facile à
faire et qui aurait pu désamorcer
éventuellement un moment la colère il
pourrait dissoudre ça me paraît pas
forcément la méthode la plus simple et
elle est très risquée pour lui reculer
sur le texte pourquoi pas mais il faut
il faut faire une réforme des retraites
qu'on le veuille ou non alors
certainement passer là il y a eu un
problème d'agenda il y a eu un problème
d'agenda on a mis entre guillemets la
charrue avant les boeufs ou plutôt on a
mis la retraite avant le travail ce
qu'on vous dit dans les cortèges c'est
qu'il y a un problème de relation au
travail en fait aujourd'hui et tout ce
qui touche à l'usure professionnel ce
qui touche à la pénibilité aux fin de
carrière cessation progressive
d'activité aux possibilités de
reconversion de reclassement ça n'a pas
été pris en considération on commence à
nous dire qu'il y aura certainement une
autre loi à ce sujet une loi travail
il fallait la faire avant alors
peut-être faut-il reculer pour revenir
avec plus de pédagogie vous savez mais
là est-ce que vous lui demandez de ne
pas promulguer le test le texte si le
Conseil constitutionnel ne le censure
pas évidemment est-ce que si le Conseil
constitutionnel valide vous dites au
président de la République il faut pas
le premier non moi je ne lui demande pas
de ne pas le promulguer je pense que
c'est à lui de prendre une décision mais
il ne peut pas faire comme il a fait
lors de son intervention télévisée comme
si les choses étaient la page était
tournée elle n'est pas tournée dans
l'esprit beaucoup de Français il ne les
a pas entendu il s'est comporté comme un
mammouth dans une manufacture de cristal
c'est un cracheur de feu il balance des
petites phrases sur les légitimité la
foule ça cristallise à coagule les
tensions et il faut renouer le dialogue
il a parlé lui-même de tendre la main il
n'avait pas répondu au courrier des
partenaires sociaux il faut
effectivement renouer le dialogue
franchement revenir en arrière c'est une
possibilité mais s'il le fait il faudra
quand même qu'on repasse par une loi sur
les retraites parce que l'avenir de
notre système par répartition il est
menacé qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer
est-ce qu'il faut changer la méthode ce
que vous nous dites ou est-ce qu'il faut
aussi changer le fond si on repasse par
une loi est-ce que sur le fond cette loi
n'était pas la bonne
écoutez le texte tel qu'il était arrivé
d'abord à l'Assemblée nationale puis
ensuite au Sénat je ne l'aurais pas voté
si je l'ai voté c'est parce qu'on l'a
considérablement amélioré qu'il s'agisse
de la prise en compte de dégradation des
maires de famille du CDI senior il y a
eu énormément d'amendements positifs sur
le fond qu'on le veuille ou non la
problématique démographique vous savez
il y avait un article d'Alfred Sauvy qui
date de 1980 qui veut dire démographie
et ne rien vouloir voir bon la
démographie on n'y peut rien on a un
vieillissement de la population on a une
baisse de la natalité il faut en tenir
compte il y a de plus en plus de
retraités je rappelle quand même que les
retraites sont payées par les actifs il
y a un rapport entre le nombre d'actifs
et de retraités qui est de plus en plus
dégradé on ne peut pas passer outre ou
alors on baisse le montant des pensions
où on augmente les cotisations ce qui
touche le pouvoir d'achat Horse un des
gros problèmes de notre pays aujourd'hui
c'est le pouvoir d'achat donc sur le
fond cette réforme il faudra la faire
peut-être
et même probablement que le présidentier
très mal pris et donc c'est à lui de
retrouver les voix du dialogue
pour la première fois dans une journée à
l'appel des syndicats on a vu des
violences en marge des manifestations
est-ce qu'on est dans un mouvement qui
est en train de changer de nature
sincèrement je n'espère pas je pense que
l'immense majorité des responsables
syndicaux même tout le responsables
syndicaux ont été très responsables
à savoir qu'ils ont rejeté toute
violence mais effectivement
des Black Blocs les antifas donc
l'extrême gauche a cherché à utiliser la
colère populaire et il y a un vent
mauvais qui souffle quand même parce que
notre réforme percute une société qui
est fragilisée il y a ces problématiques
de pouvoir d'achat prix de l'énergie le
prix de l'essence les Français ne savent
pas où ils vont ils sont dans un
brouillard ils ont l'impression aussi
que l'État répond de moins en moins à
leurs besoins à leurs attentes fait de
loin dans ce qu'on travaille je prends
un seul exemple dans l'Oise il y a eu il
va y avoir à la rentrée 40 fermetures de
classe il y en a jamais eu autant il y
en jamais eu autant donc les Français
disent attendez on nous demande que des
sacrifices que des sacrifices et on ne
voit pas où on veut nous emmener donc le
climat est très mauvais et effectivement
certains
groupes d'ultra gauche veulent en
profiter pour semer la zizanie et ça
c'est inacceptable et moi je tiens à
apporter mon soutien à tout les
gendarmes toutes les forces de l'ordre
qui font un travail très difficile dans
des conditions vraiment compliquées il y
a aussi des violences envers les élus
envers les parlementaires notamment ceux
qui ont soutenu cette réforme des
retraites vous en avez été victime vous
jetez victime d'intimidation j'ai reçu
quelques messages effectivement peu
sympathiques c'est pas la première fois
comme certains de mes collègues de loi
j'avais reçu il y a deux ans et demi une
balle dans un courrier avec un petit mot
la prochaine sera pour toi
alors effectivement ça ne fait pas
plaisir moi personnellement ça ne me
m’empêchera pas de continuer à faire mon
travail mais il y a un climat anti
parlementariste qui règne et de plus en
plus qui touche les élus même les élus
locaux il y a de plus en plus de
démission des locaux on les stigmatise
de façon très injuste parce que il se
dévoue pour le bien commun l'intérêt
général et souvent ils ne sont pas payés
en retour on va continuer à parler de
cette journée de mobilisation on va voir
comment elle s'est passé du côté de
Vichy où on retrouve Mathieu Perino
bonjour Mathieu merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous responsable de l'agence de
Vichy pour le journal La Montagne et
Mathieu ce matin vous revenez longuement
dans vos pages sur cette mobilisation
qui semble avoir connu un regain chez
vous
absolument si le président de la
République espérer convaincre les
opposants à la réforme des retraites et
apaiser la crise sociale avec son
intervention télévisée et bien c'est
clairement raté on l'a vu partout le
mouvement arganier en vigueur et il
s'est surtout
dans les territoires de la montagne et
du groupe Centre France par exemple dans
l'Allier où je me trouve on est plutôt
épargné par les phénomènes de violence
ou d'émeutes urbaines qu'on a pu
observer dans les grandes métropoles
mais la contestation reste extrêmement
forte a d'ailleurs sûrement jamais été
aussi forte qu'hier chez nous des
milliers de personnes sont descendues
dans les rues de Vichy de Moulins de
Montluçon et des groupes de manifestants
ont même mené des opérations de blocage
tout au long de la journée des blocages
de garde des blocages de route et même
la grève des éboueurs beaucoup de colère
dans les rues contre le gouvernement
contre le président de la République
surtout mais aussi contre les élus
locaux des sénateurs de l'Allier ont été
notamment interpellés à leur permanence
et le député de la troisième
circonscription de l'Allier celle de
Vichy député LR qui n'a pas voté la
motion de censure a été a été assez
vertement pris à partie hier soir lors
du conseil municipal de la commune où il
est toujours élu bref beaucoup de
tension un dialogue qui semble
totalement rompu entre les citoyens ou
en tout cas une partie d'entre eux et la
classe politique et Mathieu parmi les
manifestants de nombreux jeunes
les lycéens sont entrés dans la danse
très déterminés et souvent en tête de
cortège Baptiste 17 ans par exemple pour
lui il a décidé de manifester parce
qu'il a perdu quelques illusions en
termes de démocratie le raconte il a
découvert le 49-3 et il trouve ça
vraiment choquant Octave lui il a 18 ans
il est animateur fédéral de l'Allier et
il estime qu'en empêchant les gens de
partir plus tôt en retraite on va couper
un nombre de bénévoles importants du
monde associatif et qu'à l'arrivée c'est
les sont les plus démunis qui vont
encore trinquer du côté de
Clermont-Ferrand les lycées ont même
bloqué leurs établissements et les
jeunes plus politisés qui étaient là eux
depuis le début observe avec bonheur
cette mobilisation spontanée d'une
jeunesse qui n'avait pas forcément cette
culture de la lutte tous ils n'ont pas
peur de voir le mouvement durcir au
contraire ils sont persuadés que les
manifestations pacifiques ils le disent
ça ne sert plus à rien pour eux le 49 a
clairement ouvert une brèche un
sentiment de mépris partagé partout sur
notre zone hier dans le Cantal en
Corrèze en Creuse à Limoges à Bourges à
Orléans on le voit que cette jeunesse
s'est agrégée d'elle-même en un
mouvement au mouvement social et qu'elle
compte bien se faire entendre d'où deux
questions monsieur le sénateur d'abord
selon vous est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un bar
ou de quelque chose de plus important
parti pour durer et enfin quel message
envoyer à cette jeunesse pour qu'elle
renoue avec ses dirigeants
très honnêtement je suis surpris que la
jeunesse se mobilise autant sur ce sujet
mais il faut en tenir compte
j'ai été étudiant et en 1986 j'étais
dans les rues au moment de la réforme de
vaquets qui touchait directement la
jeunesse cette réforme est là pour but
justement d'empêcher d'endetter encore
plus la jeunesse et de payer les
retraites des retraités actuels il faut
certainement faire beaucoup plus de
pédagogie
on a entendu le président de la
République dire qu'il avait beaucoup de
courage qu'il ne voulait pas mettre la
poussière sous le tapis contrairement à
ses prédécesseurs or tous ces
prédécesseurs tous
on fait une réforme des retraites
François Hollande Nicolas Sarkozy
Jacques Chirac et dans chaque cas ça a
été problématique il y a eu des
manifestations longues pourquoi
aujourd'hui on arrive à un tel degré de
cristallisation de malaise c'est pas la
méthode a été mauvaise qu'aujourd'hui la
jeunesse rentre dans le mouvement c'est
très inquiétant parce que elle à
l'impression enfin d'après ce que
j'entends j'entends le j'ai vu des
affiches viols démocratiques au sujet du
49.3
si notre jeunesse à l'impression d'être
dans un pays qui n'est pas une
démocratie alors que nous sommes dans
une démocratie les des manifestations
sont la preuve on peut faire presque ce
que l'on veut il y a un profond malaise
alors le message envers la jeunesse
c'est déjà de l'écouter de l'entendre
mais
de ne pas tomber dans la démagogie
pédagogie plutôt que démagogie et
expliquer que nous devons
si on veut maintenir le système art
répartition faire l'effort de travailler
un peu plus je sais que ce que je suis
en train de dire ne va certainement pas
convaincre beaucoup de jeunes qui sont à
40 ou 45 ans de leur retraite mais il
faut arrêter les discours démagogiques
mais Mathieu le disait ce qui a fait
descendre une partie de cette jeunesse
dans la rue c'est l'utilisation c'est
une faute pour vous oui parce que
justement si je reviens à Jacques Chirac
et Xavier Bertrand Éric woert et Nicolas
Sarkozy Marisol Touraine on n'avait pas
utilisé ce type d'outils le 49-3 c'est
la 100e fois qu'on utilise mais pour une
réforme des retraites il faut un non
dialogue parce qu'il y avait une
majorité parce qu'il y avait une
majorité effectivement le quinquennat a
très mal commencé ça c'est sûr mais il
faut un dialogue vraiment approfondi
avec les partenaires sociaux avec les
parlementaires ce qui n'a pas été le cas
à l'Assemblée en partie à cause de
laupes qui a obstrué et aussi
effectivement avec les citoyens bien sûr
on va remercier Mathieu Mathieu Perino
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et
on regarde la une de la montagne le ton
se durcit c'est à la Une de votre
journal Mathieu on va parler d'une autre
phrase qui a été prononcée par Emmanuel
Macron et qui concerne directement le
Parlement toune passe pas par la loi
c'est ce qu'a dit le chef de l'État
mercredi dans son interview alors
comment on compte t-il gouverner on va
parler de tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Quentin calmer
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Olivier Pacaud
le chef de l'État a donc évoqué une
autre méthode pour gouverner c'est ça ce
sont quelques mots de l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron qui interroge depuis
48 heures le chef de l'État semble avoir
réalisé qu'il était véritablement
contrainte par sa majorité très relative
vous étiez en train de commencer à
l'évoquer avec Olivier Paco écouter donc
Emmanuel Macron en extrait
pour avoir à la fois moins de textes de
loi des textes plus courts plus clairs
pour aussi changer les choses pour nos
compatriotes de manière plus tangible
c'est tout ne passe pas par la loi et
donc dans ce contexte il faut agir au
service de nos priorités de nos
compatriotes le faire de manière très
concrète avec les élus sur le terrain
avec les services de l'État et tout ne
passe pas par la loi et on passe trop
par la loi dans notre République voilà
d'où cette question que l'on a vu aussi
sur le site de publics je vous conseille
ainsi que de Guillaume Jacquot qui est
revenu hier tout ne passe pas par la loi
Emmanuel Macron et Isabelle borne
peuvent-ils gouverner par décret c'est
ce que l'on comprend c'est toute la
question en fait il y a un effet
plusieurs types de normes en France la
plus élevée c'est la Constitution puis
la loi et enfin le règlement qui passe
donc par des décrets pris par le
gouvernement qui nécessite pas forcément
le vote du Parlement l'idée pour la
majorité présidentielle et donc de dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'impasse que l'exécutif
dispose encore de marge de manœuvre pour
agir écoutez sur notre plateau François
Patriat le chef des filles de chef de
fil des marcheurs au Sénat en l'écoute
il y a des mesures concrètes conscient
tout l'environnement les choses la vie
des français on peut le faire par des
grès et pourquoi pas le faire alors que
normalement aujourd'hui on annonce des
lois qui n'ont défaits bénéfiques pour
les Français que 2 ans ou 3 ans après
moi je pense que c'est une aujourd'hui
c'est une solution de sagesse alors il
faut rappeler que sans la loi il y a
quand même de nombreux domaines où
l'État ne peut pas agir et ne pas créer
de nouveaux impôts par exemple ce qui
fait dire aux spécialistes je cite que
les marges de manoeuvre de l'exécutif
s'il souhaite agir par des graisses sont
limitées politiquement cela a été vu
aussi comme un constat d'échec regardez
le tweet de votre chef de fil Bruno
Retailleau en contournant le Parlement
dont il a peur parce qu'il est
minoritaire le président de la
République avoue son impuissance
politique Olivier Paco c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre dans ces petits cette
courte phrase que l'on viendrait
entendre du chef de l'État une
impuissance politique c'est ça
alors il y a certainement une
impuissance politique mais je pense que
c'est pire je suis effectivement très
surpris de de cette une autre forme de
mépris cette fois-ci envers les
parlementaires oui il y a peut-être trop
de loi certainement mais le Parlement ce
sont les représentants du peuple qui de
façon raisonnée avec beaucoup de travail
permettent d'orienter
demander de corriger la politique
gouvernementale on ne peut pas se passer
de la loi on ne peut pas se passer de la
loi et vouloir gouverner par des crêpes
par ordonnance c'est non seulement
mépriser le peuple c'est mépriser le
Parlement c'est mépriser la démocratie
parlementaire telle qu'elle existe en
France depuis
la Troisième République
et là vous y voyez un contournement du
Parlement dans cette race pour je vois
une maladresse incroyable mais on avait
déjà eu ce type de discours plus ou
moins lors du premier quinquennat en
disant en gros le parlementaires ils
nous font perdre du temps
certainement que le Parlement prend son
temps il a pour parlementer pour pas
agir trop vite mais se passer du
Parlement c'est une erreur calamiteuse
et ça veut dire qu'il a rien compris il
a rien compris le flamboyant est devenu
arrogant avec tout le monde et il
s'enfer là il est dans des sables
mouvants mais il se plonge encore plus
depuis 2017 on avait entendu cette
critique à propos d'Emmanuel Macron sur
le fait qu'il négligeait les corps
intermédiaires c'est-à-dire à la fois
les syndicats aussi les élus locaux et
aussi les parlementaires vous allez la
sensation que avec ce qui s'est joué
mercredi autour de cette interview on en
revient à cette critique autour de ce
manque de voilà de de
compromis avec ses camps intermédiaires
il n'a rien retenu effectivement de ces
six ans au pouvoir et c'est assez
inquiétant c'est assez inquiétant oui
sur le fait de gouverner par décret vous
qui vous qui êtes parlementaire
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque est-ce
qu'il y a des vraies marges de manœuvre
selon vous
écoutez on vient d'avoir un exemple très
précis avec le zan zéro
artificialisation nette ou des décrets
d'applications ont été pris suite à
votre de la loi qui était tellement
contraire à l'esprit de la loi ils ont
dû être suspendus donc non à la
gouvernance par des grès c'est le
meilleur moyen de doubler les cortèges
dans la rue et de s'alliéner le soutien
qui peut être précieux du Parlement la
question sur la même migration oui
exactement on évoquait la web
immigration parce que le chef de l'État
a évoqué le fait de pouvoir la
saucissonner en quelque sorte la couper
en plusieurs textes peut-être deux
peut-être trois afin qu'elle passe aussi
parce qu'il y a pas des majorités sur
l'ensemble du texte et ça votre chef de
fil là encore Bruno Retailleau elle dit
hors de question vous le maintenez aussi
c'est pas possible ça paraît encore
pendant comme une manœuvre c'est à dire
on n'arrive pas en passant par la porte
on essaye de passer par la fenêtre non
c'est incompréhensible on a un président
qui alors je n'aime pas utiliser ce mot
mais qui a une forme d'autisme politique
et je pense que ça peut coûter très cher
vous êtes déçu vous deviez examiner
cette loi en séance à partir de mardi
elle a été retirée de l'ordre du jour
vous êtes déçu de ce retrait ou vous le
comprenez je le comprends parce que ça
permet peut-être d'un petit peu
d'apaiser mais je suis déçu dans la
mesure où je faisais partie de ceux qui
avaient pu travailler sur des
amendements j'avais notamment déposé
suite à une proposition de loi que
j'avais fait un amendement pour créer
une médaille de l'intégration pour
pouvoir valoriser les beaux exemples les
beaux modèles d'étrangers ou de Néo
français qui qui se sont parfaitement
intégrés donc je regrette de ne pouvais
que le texte revienne rapidement il y
aura a priori un projet de loi et il en
appelle aussi au parlementaire Emmanuel
Macron sur ce sujet écoutez moi si le
texte revient au Parlement je serai le
premier à aller débattre c'est une zone
de turbulence qui s'ouvre pour le
Parlement avec l'exécutif vous le croyez
c'est nouvelle page qui s'ouvre là
écoutez malheureusement on a cessé
d'ouvrir de nouvelles pages suite à des
crises plus ou moins grandes depuis 2017
il y a quand même une succession il y a
eu Benalla il y a eu plein de choses et
malheureusement aucune leçon n'est
retenue je suis vraiment assez déçu je
n'attendais pas forcément grand chose du
président de la République mais je me
disais qu'après donc le résultat très
serré de 2022 et cette majorité
minoritaire entre guillemets à
l'Assemblée nationale il allait mettre
de l'eau dans son absence c'est pas du
tout le cas et donc effectivement le
Parlement ne peut être satisfait de ce
qui se dit de ce qui se fait merci
on fera oui encore un tour d'horizon des
réactions à ce qui s'est joué hier la
mobilisation ce sera à suivre dans le
club à tout à l'heure Quentin on va
parler des républicains vous êtes un
proche de Xavier Bertrand Olivier Pacaud
dans l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron
mercredi avait également cette main
tendue au parlementaire les républicains
qui ont voté la réforme des retraites
est-ce qu'il faut la saisir
les républicains dont je ne fais pas
partie ont eu une attitude en tout cas
au
Senna et en grande majorité à
l'Assemblée une attitude responsable il
disait depuis longtemps nous devons
effectivement faire une réforme des
retraites et c'était dans le programme
notamment de la candidate Valérie
Pécresse il aurait été
démagogiques de ne pas s'associer en
tentant de le corriger à la volonté
réformatrice du président à ce sujet je
vous rappelle quand même que c'est pas
ce ne sont pas la républicain qui ont
changé d'avis sur leur retraite c'est le
président de la République qui a fait le
contraire en 2023 de ce qu'il avait dit
deux ans auparavant donc les
républicains sont dans une attitude
responsable ils sont au service de leur
pays
ils veulent que la France retrouve un
minimum de sérénité de prospérité et
au cas par cas selon les lois ils
peuvent éventuellement effectivement
apporter une plus-value oui de là vous
ne comprenez pas mais les députés LR qui
ont voté compte ce texte et qui ont voté
la motion de censure
il y a forcément une raison
électorale locale mais pour ceux qui
avaient défendu la candidature de
Valérie Pécresse il y a un problème de
cohérence il y a un problème de
cohérence il avait défendu la
candidature d'Orléans
à la ligne il y a aussi des voix qui
s'élèvent chez les républicains pour
dire qu'il faut passer un accord de
gouvernement avec Emmanuel Macron vous
êtes favorable non non je n'y suis pas
favorable parce que
Emmanuel Macron a incarne une ligne
politique qui n'est pas celle que
doivent inc et les républicains moi je
me sens un gaulliste social je me sens
pas du tout macroniste et je pense que
on a la France n'a pas d'intérêt à voir
un grand parti comme les républicains
devenir
supplétif de la macronie il y a des
députés qui ont voté trois qui ont
également voté la motion de censure du
rassemblement national c'est le cas
notamment de Maximino qui est député de
l'Oise comprenez-vous cette attitude
est-ce que pour vous il a franchi une
ligne rouge
maxime a été réélu en battant un
candidat du Front national donc et dans
une circonscription très difficile dont
un des cantons est celui dont je suis le
représentant donc je connais très bien
la situation donc non
si vous me demandez si Maxime minot va
aller aux Front national évidemment non
maintenant je n'aurais pas fait le même
choix que lui c'est clair vous êtes un
proche de Xavier Bertrand j'ai dit que
Xavier Bertrand alors on l'a entendu au
début sur cette réforme des retraites et
mettre des réserves poser trois
conditions notamment au vote de cette
réforme et puis là ces derniers jours au
moment où la situation se tendait chez
les républicains ont la plus entendu ces
regrettable ce silence
je pense qu'il prendra la parole dans un
futur proche très honnêtement je ne le
sais pas je ne l'ai pas vu depuis un
certain temps je peux vous dire quand
même que contrairement à ce que certains
ont pu dire il y a pas eu de mot d'ordre
chez les amis de Xavier Bertrand pour
voter contre le texte moi
personnellement il m'a pas passé de
téléphone pour me dire il faut que tu
votes contre tu tapes tiennes maintenant
la clarification est toujours profitable
donc sachant que Xavier connaît très
bien la problématique des retraites
qu'il est issu d'un territoire très
populaire il faut certainement qu'il
s'exprime pour éviter de laisser penser
certaines choses bien sûr donc dans les
prochains jours très rapidement pourquoi
pas je j'ai pas à lui dicter sa conduite
mais moi je le souhaiterais et la fonder
un mouvement est-ce qu'il est en train
petit à petit de prendre son
indépendance des républicains
il faut lui demander à lui vous le
connaissez je le connais mais j'espère
que vous sentez exactement
je ne sais pas je pense qu'il faut qu'il
soit effectivement c'est difficile
d'avoir un pied dans nos France et un
pied dans les républicains moi
personnellement j'ai fait le choix
d'être nulle part je suis rattaché au
groupe mais je suis pas dans le dans le
parti je pense que la clarification est
toujours préférable merci Olivier Pacot
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première